sur la façade de cette maison un vélo de
course un vélo d'appartement de marc
bernard hinault une table de jardin avec
des casques de cyclistes comme si des
coureurs du tour de france s'était
arrêté pour se rafraîchir
nous sommes chez daniel quelque part en
touraine le voici daniel il vient
d'aller chercher son journal
alors hop le mans pousse et ça lui mais
bon avec les bons il ya le tour c'est
bien fait bah voilà daniel comme tous
les jours suis devant son petit écran
les étapes du tour de france car le vélo
c'est son truc
et vous n'êtes pas au bout de vos
surprises prise de contact alors daniel
le tour cette année penseront mal quand
même on a des français qui se débrouille
bien
from est au dessus du lot on fait avec
ah le vélo ils l'aiment la preuve c'est
lui il y en a partout
accessoires compris dans la salle à
manger le salon l'escalier les chambres
des combles et même au plafond toutes
les pièces y passe
c'est une passion qui m'aimait tout
petit que mes parents n'avaient pas de
moyens que j'adorais le cyclisme dont
jacques anquetil qu'on écoute et à la
radio parce qu'il n'y avait pas beaucoup
de télévision à l'époque et j'avais mes
parents n'avaient pas les moyens on
pourrait pas acheter je pouvais pas me
payer un vélo alors j'ai travaillé en
campagne pour fait pour me payer mon
premier vélo en 1962 et il en a acheté
des vélos
il s'est arrêté de compter à 300 dans
les dépendances même tarif des vélos des
vélos et encore des vélos sous les vélos
que je trouve je les trouve bof c'est
pour ça que je les garde parce que je
trouve magnifique mais cela va bien
non pas spécialement peut-être à la
limite amont colnago quand j'ai fait le
tour des flandres que j'ai pris du
plaisir en belgique à faire le tour des
flandres
alors peut-être celui ci parce que quand
on a goûté c'est la ferrari du vélo
daniel regrette de choses ne pas avoir
fait la carrière de jacques anquetil son
idole ne pas avoir collectionné les
ferrari pour de vrai en attendant
l'arrivée du tour ils espèrent trouver
un autre passionné à jour qui aurait de
la place pour
ouvrir son musée